So that's really interesting.
Everyone's heard of Watson,
IBM's Watson,
and everybody knows that
Watson won Jeapordy!
I think a lot of people realize IBM
is now trying to move Watson into
healthcare.
The results you just
described are really amazing.
Do you think that we're heading
into an era down the road,
where tools like Watson
are going to replace doctors?
>> So first,
before I answer that question,
first I want to give a little background
about how Watson compete in Jeopardy.
Besides the advanced analytics
techniques they have used,
the amazing natural language processing
pipeline they have developed.
Another secret I think is very important
for the success of Watson winning
Jeopardy is to reach training
data source that are available
that related to Jeopardy challenge.
In fact, there is a website
called www.jarchive.com that
record all the historical competition
in the past in Jeopardy since 1983.
And a lot of those questions
are general knowledge
that there are associate Wikipedia
articles that provide very
rich meta information
about those questions.
So those two important data sources
helped the Waston Team to develop their
algorithms, to train their algorithms
on those historical questions.
So that lead to a very amazing result.
But in medicines,
neither of those sources are available.
There is no good question database or
question/answer database that available.
There's no good matter information
related to all those clinical concepts.
So it's a lot more complicated
even to get to that stage.
So what they have done before I left is,
they look at the US medical
licensing exam questions.
And trying to at least
tackle that first.
Because those are the available
questions and answers.
But just the space of
the medical domain is so large.
And the question and answers are a lot
of times there's no clear yes and
no answers.
So it's a lot harder.
But clinical institutions are very
interested in using Watson.
So there's a very big medical
research center at MD Anderson,
I mean,
Sloan Kettering Memorial Cancer Centers.
They all partners with Watson,
to use Watson for their diagnosis.
So that's definitely
a promising direction.
I hope they succeed.
>> It's fascinating to speculate
about what something like
Watson might be able to do, if you could
train it on that vast amount of data.
So as you look ahead for the next few
years, five years or so, where do you
think we're going to be in terms of
big data and analytics in health care?
>> Yeah, so
it's definitely a very hot area.
Big data analytics in health care.
And so there's a paradigm
shift from the traditional,
more small scale statistic approach,
to a more system approach.
When I say system,
I mean computing system.
So they're not single
algorithm that going to work.
It's a pipeline of sufficity
computational tasks that put together
and run in a various scalable platform
like high performance computing centers
or in a cloud environment
like Amazon web services.
So, in particular,
I think there is a great need for
making the data more useable.
Using analytics techniques.
So, there's a new push
called phenotyping.
That really means, how do you
convert those messy electronic
health records into meaningful
clinical concepts using algorithms?
Rather than require the data to be good
to begin with, why don't we develop
algorithm that can automatically clean
the data and turn them into more usable
high quality data that can
support research and discovery?
So that's the phenotyping effort
that a lot of people are working on.
That's about the input to
the analytics platform.
Then, there's the middle part,
where people are trying to view those
analytics, predictive analytics.
That used to take months, like for
every disease target, every data set,
you have to spend months just to
get the right data, view the model,
then validate that.
But now, everybody want to use
predictive analytics and there's
thousands of disease and conditions
people want to view the model for.
So how can you scale up to
view this model quickly?
You need a very scalable,
large scale platform to support that.
So, alot of people leveraging
parallel computing and
like map redo's to do that kind of work.
That's the processing part.
And also, finally, the output, right?
So we so far only talk about accuracy
and how good the models are.
But in order to make use of those
model in clinical decision support,
you really have to make
the model intuitive.
So that the decision maker,
like clinician, doctor can understand.
Can explain the result to the patients,
so that they believe and
follow through the recommendation.
And their work on leveraging
similar patients' history and
recommend what worked for
the similar patient to the current
patient as intuitive method to
explain the recommendations.
So that's the final output part, right?
So all the entire system,
input processing and
output need to be new
computational method.
And I think that's very a promising
future for health care analytics.
>> Well thank you very much.
I think you really helped
the students understand,
not only where we are, but
to see that there are many,
many years of interesting research and
development ahead of us.
So maybe some students
will decide to join that,
which would be a great result.
So thank you very much.
>> Thank you.